und jetzt reden wir endlich mal über das
bauen meine damen und herren und über
bauschutt der macht nämlich 60 prozent
unseres abfalls aus und wir diskutieren
immer noch über coffee to go becher oder
strohhalme umso besser dass sich die
politik nach 15 jahren streit und
verhandlungen endlich auf einen
recycling kompromiss für bauschutt
geeinigt hat im november abgesegnet vom
bundesrat aber jetzt schon wieder
ausgebremst von wer weiß horst seehofer
ja die bayerische bauwirtschaft ist
dagegen hätte man da als
bundesbauminister nicht einfach mal dem
lobby druck aus der heimat widerstehen
können schade bauens tatsächlich ein
wichtiges thema wie wollen wir in
zukunft wohnen nicht mehr in
einfamilienhäusern
wenn es nach dem grünen
bezirksamtsleiter in hamburg nord geht
in den stadtteilen fuhlsbüttel und
langenhorn kriegt man tatsächlich keine
genehmigung mehr für ein neues
einfamilienhaus ein mutiger grüner move
im superwahljahr von den machern des
veggie days wenn du wirklich gehasst
werden willst verbietet dem deutschen
einfamilienhaus kötter und grillen tipp
von mir meine klar niemand mag verbote
wir sind alle erwachsen andererseits in
einem so dicht besiedelten land wie
deutschland müssen wir tatsächlich
wahrscheinlich bald ja anders bauen
gerade beim klimaschutz kommt man am
bausektor gar nicht vorbei
dabei ist der für mehr als ein drittel
des weltweiten co2 ausstoßes
verantwortlich
rund acht prozent der globalen co2
emissionen gehen allein auf die
zementindustrie zurück allein bei der
produktion von zement entstehen jedes
jahr drei milliarden tonnen co2 mehr als
beim gesamten flugverkehr und allen
rechenzentren der welt zusammen
fürs klima wäre es im vergleich sogar
besser sich ein auto mit verbrenner zu
kaufen wenn man dann auch drin wohnt
würde und das ist ein hochspannender
gedanke würde die zementindustrie ein
land sein dann wäre die zementindustrie
auf platz drei weltweit
punkt eins kann man nicht vor der
sendung auf toilette gehen zweitens ist
wirklich hoch interessant china auf
platz 1 dann usa dann zementindustrie
kinder ich habe urlaub in der
zementindustrie gebucht china hat wohl
von 2011 bis 2013 so viel beton
hergestellt und verbaut wie die usa in
ihrer kompletten geschichte
die chinesen lieben zement ja so ist so
bauen frist unglaublich viele ressourcen
und für beton braucht man ja zum
beispiel auch ohne ende sand in einem
einfamilienhaus stecken 200 tonnen sand
in nur einem kilometer autobahn 30.000
tonnen
wow sand ist das neue gold setzt sein
geld nicht in den sand investieren st
sowie er hier viel besser als bekannte
bitcoin sand dafür stehe ich mit meinem
guten namen
ich mache in sand konnten früher auch
nur katzen sagen tatsächlich ist sandte
am meisten benötigten rohstoff nach
wasser aber was müssen wir in
deutschland konkret besser machen
meerholz häuser bauen und ganz wichtig
weniger fläche versiegeln von arealen
wie diesen werden täglich knapp 60
hektar in deutschland in verkehrs- oder
siedlungsflächen umgewandelt
jedes jahr gehen so flächen verloren die
etwa dem stadtgebiet von hannover
entsprechen so schlimm schlimm
warum versehen war stattdessen nicht
einfach jeden tag hannover eigentlich
sollten in deutschland bis 2020 nur noch
30 hektar am tag versiegelt werden
dieses ziel hat die gruppe aber auf
2.030 verschoben weil das ist später
hier muss tatsächlich ein umdenken
einsetzen am besten schon bei den
kleinsten leute ich habe da hinten ein
unberührtes stück wald gefunden
wunderschön schnell das müssen wir
zubetonieren ich schmeiße ford meinen
mich da ist platz für zehn
einfamilienhäuser aber wir bauen nur ein
großes drauf können wir ganz deutschland
versiegeln
das alles nächste woche bei bob die
umwelt
bob die umwelt so schöne anregung
vielleicht für den wdr kinderchor im
nachhinein sage ich ihn ärgere ich mich
total dass ich damals nach dem abi nicht
in die zementbranche gegangen bin
so wie christian ehring ihm gehört ein
zementwerk am niederrhein und das läuft
super nach allem was ich höre christian
ja ich muss wirklich sagen es gibt
nichts schöneres
gerade jetzt bei diesen minusgraden
sitze ich hier abends 1400 grad zement
ofen trinken reise tasse kakao und lese
meine kontoauszüge jeder der kein
zementwerk hat ist einfach nur dumm
zement ist quasi der zement der unser
land zusammenhält
jeder deutsche anschnallen verbraucht
pro jahr 330 kilo zement wo hab ich denn
330 kilo zement ja gucken sie mal hinter
sich
tatsächlich mein zement und was mache
ich denn jetzt damit keine ahnung
irgendwas bauen immer weiter bauen ganz
wichtig mein ofen darf niemals ausgehen
guck mal jetzt verbrennen wir autoreifen
sieht aus wie ein doofer sketch aus der
heute so aber wir verbrennen wirklich
autoreifen und nicht nur die von den
rund 40 zementwerken in deutschland
haben die meisten mittlerweile die
genehmigung bis zu 100 prozent abfall zu
verbrennen
erlaubt ist fast alles siedlungsabfälle
kunststoffe altreifen zum teil auch
klärschlämme oder lösemittel wie geil
ist das denn bitte
wir brauchen überhaupt keine kohle mehr
oder anderen teuren quatsch wir
verfeuern müll und kriegen dafür auch
noch geld fall weniger entsorgen ja
immer rein damit
und der clou ist während echte
müllverbrennungsanlagen mit teurer
abgasreinigung arbeiten müssen uns bei
uns ein alter staubfilter moment mal
ehring wir haben noch ein
bundesemissionsschutzgesetz das regelt
klar wie viel dreck eine fabrik
ausstoßen darf völlig richtig enthält
aber eine ulkige fußnote in der
sinngemäß steht ja ja bla bla gilt nicht
für zwingend werke weil achtung
systemrelevant ja genau wie diese
komischen pfleger für die alle immer
klatschen wir haben eine
sondergenehmigung beispiel schwefelgase
statt 50 milligramm pro kubikmeter
dürfen zementwerke bis zum achtfachen
ausstoßen
beim giftigem kohlenmonoxid sogar bis
zum 60 fachen sagen wir mal so ich
selber wohne privat natürlich nicht
neben meinem zementwerk es ist wirklich
es ist ein traum wir dürfen praktisch
alles verfeuern
meine neue entsorgungs kooperation mit
der italienischen cosa nostra läuft
super
gelebtes europa christian ehring
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den kanal abonniert und
nike dallas ich hab die schnauze voll
loslassen abo da